cnn chief medical correspondent at chief
medical reporter in euros surgeon and
also be talking about
polarino i a character the afternoon
information analyst of him on
television broadcast
here is that the san diego figures joshua
your doctor route
him bureau thanks for he may be 3d
vision arnolda  and like oil praise you
give me some time nike rival just opened
for you and say what do you think people
china first and most about what is going
on in this world that the route
does have an alibi title cause
nuisance cats le mans china so  so
new by his third spreading to the
world with its borne color a new
were speakers in the effect in my
three before and so they let sausage omar
things were it i had to keep whether your
doctor toaster the heavy for tea
drinking be
had to scan the  world mike is too fluid
to text god and see him if i
just camp holland
so a simple him rudder finch al bonobos
to swipe steeple and legacies no that
's an i  do it for particular
existing conditions will there be errors that
snake dries time that is a hypertension
purmerweg and there but i will be
like i put nl
islam that disadvantage nice talk about why is
this is something that can battle from
person to person a week in  action
ages train the trees that spread
and right now time killer
he they look at musing when they
dun and sisters how you know it and the then
each other and you how to be has us
me and hi diego and then sir half and
the and so
content for in for practicing hell
videos way how it ski power gel
mousse time then i have the truck that there
are both with the proctor himself
those behaviors you i sit with the them
doing an earthly spheres themselves with for the
people around it  ripple unfortunately and
then clockwise to i african
blend mx die for organic the fire so
pandemic
boys
in brielle optimistic science night
shift in china' there someone points chine
en with numbers in his house  by the dow
it will be great salt and places like
singapore and hong kong
content i will be there previous just dance
a crime here a sauna hammam we will
do that thing the mistakes orders
voice of knife become a l and then you want
him time to be brain  step speakers
who app to help and rotterdam in
worship jerry moving forward are
exactly what the feature to test and
dusting the week in duno through a gate
and i think your magic magic in daven's
along with far sides received in the
video and the and and in  kino videos tanks
and i also get there in the political tour
de lasalle the santa valve men
stepping around the timing in doctor san
diego to see and street Merkel hitchhike
technically can in your podcast that
crowns of respect burssens faction the
richest just a very check  out my girl
rising show
testing let's talk about sex him die
sportsvan governments charles barkley god
the sixth in time utah jazz organization
die test
arjan testing dat de group to work and
you chal  ice well testing to potentially
gamer earn idea mother the scoop
the talk about the future i do you think
about the public sector private sector
en let the public sector typically
takes charge love in this kind of business
interview is a like this and
and leave the ruins and  that even kind
at the sector in soon to milly coming
to my and again in the mare white
and the situation the private sector and z
minus the brook that i tortoise tortoise
monk and engrossed severity and on tasks
to relations at glencore and issue
neatly the idea  have a physiological dr
who wants to image the resources and who wants to go to space
always time had so
by term en eventually become and
excel this minnow by with nothing week and
banquet his nature weedze the farmer in the
idea how hard but I think with my  ex
vliet and the snacks then week from more
monkey formation well to that we take 100
years she did you
2000 rcd and and the deed mistake you see that
a lot you don't tomorrow
millions in mi  jn perdition i can be that
many people who could i it there is that
church and zanen
source the try it better idea
address becomes the temptation like a
widespread the cerise
we do have asmr chinese and doctor
at the obsessions hunting metaphorical
mobi tone have eyeliners wnl  and and
minutes best dictates and but the streets
design for you to all hardware
that sense and the weeds measurement sundance
ii my roots carries a great fast
discus idol idol gilly 0x oakley
again so versus in spreading most
robust flash mini the note
wel wie autumn  and the chocolate for
en monami de ask you in the guards die
social destin thing which you need a
wall practical hi jean at my my high
jump right this is a few and en vice
versa roof hatch hell hell cambodia ladies
1st yamina allali saburo see the  oil
sporting events knows recordings on post
malone cultured and the rapt and ze
cable and metals 2000 people in in
denver last night harold ramis a page
marina minatica aan je nou leuk aan m  ike
shine there's an old north cradock
entry and little b basically put in
a workshop down and very large area de
can say you're very large population czc
pump 16 million in you in the ub
[ __ ] yeah so that dat they snater santing that
for  like within shira brands
but incline here to the president
idea is crunchy likely be the planning
and national mertens in the helmet beneath
triggers and hurt sea okay well it's
point right point in which you just
dance-coach here the pan you for you
prevent knife gathering syrian point
where
large corporations red cedar and pleats
will become of my this point for
barb never have a came the
color tick a d min r yes you well okay
worked through president trump and the
promotions so
there are none to his and there  is
to mine who often this my ear and 10
you had to i just in lovina week after soon
tinder so know who a section here are
smallpox in right now slowing
down again happening right now
i think i just had one in a very
very long time summer and never happened
but so i think the dress was mentink it was
ordinary sander see the medics i know one
here that your view does matter
together service engelina him in concert
look in  mecam daan the between
carnation
peter kennaugh prima gathering are in
modern size and am happy to define a
wider the rest will be soon and after release
putten
well i know it is a bsc health
retina share my recession japanese people
were together they can test en sam's
elzelies  tree the section
there is what i again the spread and so it
becomes that all that stinger
fundamentally about this final fascinates
dislike what transmission
it becomes flat in width transmission
of hyvers kendo van hotels we well
billions keeps
shiny and so deep in brake pads lake
with transmission with time the true
starts to give out and who you know from
rose and and that keeps the who who weed
wieven helps the west end and x in the
closet and food sars
must  are other drivers so that
deadpool on the goal
it's a different party is well and and
it me so my action bimond models
their people
share that is summary we see you guys on
the ismes gathering is become a
counselor avoid those in somebody'
so they came  in a d'er 62
must be able to help if i money partner
there point is run along
push it god side hits racing and finger
out especially the people
so between news test it to them this
may come and count hercules and honestly
oh fine as that pot  and maitrise and mikey
elsewhere that problem do you ever have in him
even for a layman that is not prodigy
merkel concerns the primary concern
what you that you that social disruption
and that the people who help him
about efforts the edible public  je
less xango fine de if keeper
significant after too expensive act is i
like a child so well the santing laws
in the middle ages pandemic worked see
whether then you op up xl tiny
final people who attended  in particular
concerts and science at sex and bkd mee
die
de tent will in fact it in and by the
way they may nou al again a fc the
people may from of everything there is pi-man
recognize van but by ever passing
back the
home ever  good did i do i think
of tacos eyepiece
you can you can see hear and ff this is
a knife gathering like that in in a
mystery pandemic
death in medical and social search
concern couple more minutes late becomes
actors are group de scene and chief
medical cross pans  cure another giant
show some people listening to was a
watch as lightning dock for sale village there
the potential in smart community they
here to it getting about brands
grappling matter show or pushing led
the kids links finish up there links
argiletz seniors
gross-liedern thor  high school things
and preparing for baseball preparing for
spring sports and novices tilt
pinolino breeze in the voices skills and
they were using just to those people
right now
dat de route d  us i have to go as far as rijnmond
i have cover the history have that
smoothing the verso timing and
luino becoming next power when the weather is
ready and you just have the president's
nothing and i'm in have bad guy who
and festival find
chicken dory 6 a star weekend with  i
can say i know that may come down as
part of a s100 and see the die him 3 cm
from the nes otherwise you will see all those scored
piece sometimes and push them some tf and
in the sunny's courses of the be
answered he who was  just a few things what
the score closing sympathetic in which and
and the app works so and and fat on this
is wet floor and and wargaming at the
z10 how to lure tea
dennis there a score coachings and the pole
on
much of the banner further there osb  stand
but our tool kit table
draw strether early and think in read
more floor and why kids that a
place we mess around and holder kids
share
what it's like infection and middle want in
my kids
if we want in sex here and so and
there  low effect  is different
from what i spread it is not likely
so blanket that core the pointers to bali
will there one in the center sit still
strether the nou livelink
so to nachos by snl for school
closing
ultimately booty black babe almost six
or a link sausage also grappling traders
and think that can be effective i think
before in terms of situation where ah music
sport for that you will have worked exactly
that is always easy because you
estimate the sides falls to me rival ground you
so a weak the weather polar score
say mouse name to water
work  and he is in the that's another him
if a large the half christmas people
know your work is so serious
porn healthcare workers are the am i
them next about the timing you don't
and acquaintances that score closing
you want i have i it there ripple effect  and
and itself as the word and waiting in line
is a travel agency relations at h and it
that you see so
amino what that what that fits in so new
and if masco are sharpie try the malfunction
something one  and one
the russians have 100 score score to the
country in on fifty an hour video live
and in became respect i know you and i
dunno there was a liquid they become
color being the badger was i work lies
here in the set we again  fack it is
much had i work was in run
willy not that it became in that in
danish te kana how i did it yes that's
all that's rough managers finish on me
die lesson because for you me combined you
and and in a view any comments  or hire
where's the doctor san diego
some fans warp no masters
postman
threads en vdab is suspended hello
you think this will last shot list and
the jim and shirley er prevention
wat music right people to do on a daily
base is to try and help in the
prevention of the spread is buyers that the
coup de coeur
yes regretted the stock prices mikey
we call the toes the canon hairy
redhead i have my work and my tassel
to sister now normal and then there
is still a ticket to my mouth and i do i do
in  ahoy d  he trade sir beebe this a
new address and if necessary another oriental
there a new new delhi in about serina
and i a suite sets what videos can
we him it should exactly and allie
haze modern more robust a serbian they
would be exactly and the  word i knew
that
kind you not there tomorrow scudder further
darcy to the peaks kind it seemed marc
charlier pro
he keeping up saske even if ever from
rise to summarize
so that seems happening again here so
is those very things are nice site floor
and flood  if is a tanker and its
seasonality the laws of the bag to
dino and sons weathercam the number so
down and so what i it cooler in the base
is likely the start je nou mood things
better numbers
keep in mind menzis where they sorting
line and ran  works both to it also
what she him earlier that so german come back
maxi is a wimey him she numbers type to
the countries or more
leaves it where men app provides
god becomes a red ants that
see him earn  pen how dig experts
means weeks there was the view but
the that farmer watch this
and the prix 4-season on and and the
next on the finger the protection and
in one here in his train is even
elite automatic basic people are
on it and  dennis valve pacino there so
respect roy otherwise will apply the engine
snieders respiratory droplets
released in the three years after i go to
that never i never got me sixty
here well that i have a marry for
that they don't down if we three years roots
in and  the blankets tdr charlotte bed and
fans with their way of d i falls my
door to certis is so type data here is
the medina
so bible particles insider effectory
droplets and clear clients net family
procedure insects so a monells i
got tricks again we your hair
textures off
simsek than coke here more visions have
a sec dark at him how it
rejection and i bring the word opportunities
retouching dear is getting old
i think we were nice count you then
touch thing them  t she to practico what easy
washer it is and now so a sec
services
you let live likely to get niro to
have where is transmitted here at
yourself by touching her eyes gymnasium
11h but the one de dundas pc games will
apply and then i think you  never and he
makes contact serious idea here parents
doorne know sevn is he sloppy and you are
completely white the news cover t
deeper there are people of the fine and
the and will be week i think
barbara's free
so how you on it and solid half ipo
people  who then have that sentence
week well stop just european people
address
so far this is my cairns and wanna make
certain time
consider myself is the tent oil will
minutes twente with remove they are so
all those all those that basic hygienic art
our leads to new job
he  must absolutely who they stand there are a
thousand the truth is to eastside
tardis that builds eye-to-eye en es
it be and they we think you who will create
you the week in all we leave
youtube  n what attention
and living is wanting to import from
an ex who goes to the next few weeks for
something like that fake of an excel ruiz en
particular if yes nina highlight the
hague wtf expert 11 and and zoey how you
architect have a service
the action group  te riele plush time
really enjoy your work pair a name
he got one match
yes my cousin 30 cm bettina petticoat
iphone ipad is the raik alright the number
people who here like edese are
overreaction this is the white house in
order to do what you say  nothing the water bottle
or let me curve make sure the
healthcare system is closely related
correct
this is reality okay aw
subscription but so 10 times podcast could
fairfax versus fiction dixi-kot the
technology reflecting ambuiki
needed and here at ted started sanjay
gupta chief medical  cold man or crm